[Music]
welcome to generation zero explores
breaking water here in New York City we
have some of the best drinking water on
the planet but it's not like that all
over the world
we sent peanut carnival to a chicane
reservoir to interview Matt Mahoney to
find out what New York City does right
and learn how the best tap water in the
world gets delivered here on the
Catskills the ashcan reservoir and this
reservoir sees most of New York City
with fresh clean water we call out with
Matt Mahoney who works for Suez to Isis
a company that provides water over 92
million people look at my generation do
about water conservation well you know
you're already doing something right now
you have a water bottle reusable water
bottle and that's really one of the keys
become a conservationist all to yourself
so bottle board you can pay for anything
one two three dollars for a bottle of
water but your average cost of top bar
is about a penny a gallon across United
States there's a real drop-off there in
terms of price in terms of value it's
just not efficient at all the bottle of
trunk water places and I think that the
convenience factor is something that
cities have sort of missed the Train on
people want to make a healthier choice
and water is always the healthier choice
than bottled soda or juices or anything
like that sugary drinks so in that sense
people are making a positive choice for
their life but they're making a negative
choice for the environment when I buy
bottled water
so what considers you I think the answer
really what cities and governments could
do is a lot more what they do in Europe
where there are a lot of public
fountains that are available to drink so
if you walk the Rome for example there's
public fountains everywhere the filled
with great tap water that comes out and
it has to be accessible in New York City
I helped create a program called water
on the go it's still in existence today
after about five years ception more on
the go or public mobile water fountains
that go to areas where there are going
to be a lot of New Yorkers and tourists
places like Times Square Herald Square
Union Square and as well as big outdoor
events and festivals that go on
throughout the city and that allows
people to come up free of charge and
fill up their water bottle reusable
water bottles and get some clean fresh
near to the tap water and that's a great
way of highlighting tap water that
cities can do all
country and I think New York City has
some unique qualities to it and the
thing that makes it that way I was
really the source waters often the
Catskill Mountains you know it's sort of
this pristine land 130 miles north of
the city and it's conveyed by two giant
aqueducts the Catskill the delaware
aqueduct that come down to the city and
that water has just the right taste of
just the right acidity produces some of
the best breads in the world so those
pizza bagels in the world and people
don't nuts for it and people often try
to emulate that there when you're
outside the city that their water is
like New York City water or that their
food is made with New York City water in
some cases I'm not sure how they do that
but if you look at our shoreline
especially you see countless bottles
bags garbage and tressa put in there I
think that there's really a lack of
understanding that water is really a
cycle and the water that's in the ocean
is eventually the water that you drink
through condensation and the entire
water cycle and that's missed a lot of
people so I think there's a lack of
education on it and I think it's
something that also needs to be taken
more seriously by the authorities I
think that they sort of these people
sort of turned a blind eye to legal
dumping and
getting rid of trashes in the waterways
it's really a change when New York
City's population exploded in the early
1900's New York was already in economic
and political powerhouse they had the
foresight to know that an abundant
source of drinking water would be key to
New York future what about today though
in an age of unlimited corporate
political contributions what if you are
politically and economically weak
community and you're trying to protect
your own drinking water
we interviewed Lance King of Lakota
tribal leader fighting to protect the
drinking water with people we can't live
without water just and you know horses
were bonded back then everyone's ride
and beeps chatter snuffles let you ride
the horse to decisions riding around for
a little bit having fun you know just
not not having a care of anything you
know and it was close it was somewhat
like you got that feeling of how it
might have been back in 89
why would you want to live why would you
want to live something different want a
food crisis now are you the boss to my
great-granddaughter pretty shot is
pipeline down a little bit the people
that I ride like water gold veins inside
by now
[Music]
[Music]
apparently the pipeline was originally
supposed to go through Bismarck above
Bismarck and Andover and all the people
of Bismarck said no you know like they
didn't want that because of the chance
of leakage and breaking of pipelines so
they rerouted it down further under
under Bismarck to where if anything
would have burst or whatever then it
wouldn't be in their water or whatever
so that's where really hit you know the
tribes so I just looked over to these
guys and I said my name is Lance King
remember me and you know I just went
forward I didn't know if anything was
going to happen but I wasn't you know
you can't trust you know I mean at that
at that point you know at that time
anything was possible so I just told my
name and I walked forward and I went to
the bridge and spoke to people and they
were you know eventually it was pretty
intense this guy had his hand on his gun
you know when I was standing there and I
was again that's what I didn't know if
anything was going to happen but I knew
that I had to go there because that's
why I went there was to show my support
you know physically and spiritually and
if that's what if that's what was going
to happen I was what was going to happen
and I got to say that right there was
probably because based on the past
experiences of what I've seen them shoot
that protectors with was the water the
water cannons the rubber bullets and you
didn't know any you have no idea when
you're if you're gonna get shot when
your [ __ ] shot life is based on
happiness loss sharing
helping kindness growing teaching and
you can't do any of that without water
lance and his Native American and
environmentalist allies lost their fight
to keep the pipeline from their
watershed oil industry supporters argue
the economic benefit of extracting
Canadian shale oil supersedes the water
concerns of the Sioux tribe as witnessed
by water crisis in Flint Michigan
southern India the Ganges and the Niger
Delta healthy clean water for everyone
requires a strong sense of community and
stewardship but it also requires
political will and resources here in New
York City
we're blessed a quality the next time
you come here bring one of these and
don't look like Horace
[Music]